it's time to take on your biggest
challenge yet
creating a dessert worthy of going viral
that is a sneak peek and my guest
co-host tamara mori housley hosting her
new show baker's dozen it's streaming
right now on hulu we put amateur bakers
against professional bakers there are a
lot
of self-taught bakers out there who have
amazing talent so
i love that they stepped into their
passion
with just
faith riana
what is happening here um what is it
though about these baking shows cause i
admit i love every single one of them i
get into all of them but what is it
about them that people just kind of
gravitate i know right
i feel like it's just feel good tv yeah
not only are the shows just visually
stunning yes but you're learning jedi
mind
yes right you're learning at the same
time there are a lot of people who say
after they've watched the show they're
inspired to try and remake what someone
has made you do love to bake you are so
it's my name tamara
do your babies get in the kitchen with
you absolutely they do yes
ever since the pandemic because we were
all stuck together
after a while we were looking at each
other like oh
what are we
my son can cook breakfast lunch and
dinner come on yep and my daughter she
made eggs the girl can crack an egg
flawlessly like she is fantastic you
better hone that crap are they are the
kids creatives it's in the dna so do
they have any other choice no
once i saw my daughter she didn't know i
was watching she was looking at herself
in the mirror and i was like oh lord and
she was just acting
hi and then once she found out that i
actually do christmas like hallmark
films yeah she literally said mommy can
i be in your next movie so
you never know definitely and you spoke
about you know doing the hallmark movies
it is only fall but it's christmas at
the hallmark channel year round yes i
have one coming out yeah you do have one
coming out it's called the santa
stakeout did that make you want to like
get in early start decorating early i
was like adam can we can we put up the
christmas decorations you know just like
november 1st
and he was like absolutely not now that
you have babies um and you got you know
you are your own little family what's
your favorite christmas tradition
my fam my favorite christmas tradition i
would have to say is decorating yeah
decorating together
we put on christmas movies as we
decorate we um i drink
i have like a a glass of wine a baby
it's all good
it's mommy juice
and then i also i say this your first
child
mommy juice right second child you need
the hard liquid yeah brown liquor you
move on
mommy's drink now is whiskey i love it i
love it